you know the 1 through 10 scale  everybody knows about this okay  would you say that guys know their score  um i think that guy men generally  undervalue themselves and women over  value themselves okay and the reason for  that is because there's no such thing as  a plus size male model right um and  there shouldn't be i'm not look i'm not  trying to buy draws if i see a dude my  size wearing those drums do you  understand what i'm saying but but by  the same token women are taught to feel  good about themselves no matter what  like janito fantastic figure we have  women who are literally four times  janeta's size like i don't know maybe  lizzo and every time she takes a bikini  picture lizzo smolders the internet with  a red hot well of course if lizzo gets  that kind of pub then of course the  average rank and file girl who's  probably a five thinks she's a seven